[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy friday if you've
been living in america over the past few
years you've definitely had this
experience you wake up one morning and
you realize
that some institution you grew up with
the group you once loved and trusted has
somehow changed completely it's not what
you remember it's unrecognizable in fact
it's now insane
chances are that's happened at the
school you went to maybe to the church
you grew up in or a charity you've long
supported they're very different if
you're an episcopalian you know exactly
what we're talking about if you've ever
given money to the sierra club hoping
they i don't know protect the sierras
you get it too
so everywhere in this country formerly
respectable organizations seem to have
gone off the deep end
have you listened to national public
radio recently
now admittedly npr was always a little
nutty but in a familiar non-threatening
kind of way your average public radio
station ran niche cultural programming
most of the time the celtic music hour
or a bluegrass show in fact for decades
public radio's most popular feature was
something called car talk remember that
it was a show where two italian
mechanics from boston hilarious both of
them argued about the relative merits of
carburetors versus fuel injections they
gave you free advice on how to fix your
honda
and then in the morning and again and
night as always in drive time all npr
stations aired the news from washington
there was morning edition in the morning
there was all things considered on the
trip home
npr anchors were left of center
obviously but more than anything they
were self-consciously upmarket
they spoke in comically stilted voices
designed to suggest deep addition
you could imagine them reading a lot of
rilka in their spare time and having
complicated opinions about wine
this is npr they'd say national public
radio
it was all pretty amusing easy to mock
but it was basically harmless npr didn't
call for violent revolution or denounced
white people as demons
that did happen on some radical stations
like pacifica but not at npr and npr
they were just dopey self-important 70
thousand liberals
the kind of dangly earrings and
composting bins in their yards
not anymore you ought to listen to npr
now actually don't listen we pulled the
clips for you
keep in mind that what you're about to
hear is entirely real all of it aired on
npr over just the last few weeks
first up is a segment about dieting and
that seems like a sensible topic
obviously the country could use some
help dropping weight particularly with
covet in the air
but npr doesn't run straightforward
segments anymore on anything
so it never occurred to them to air a
feature about how to rid yourself of
extra christmas pounds no a segment like
that would be racist it has nothing to
do with equity or marginalized
communities so instead here's how npr
approached dieting listen
i am a chinese-american non-binary
therapist and psychologist and dei
consultant
chang specializes in research and
treatment of eating disorders within
marginalized communities in the bay area
they say decoupling from diet culture is
often eye-opening and also
uncomfortable
decoupling from diet culture
are you following this by the way you
can't even have a conversation without
certain prerequisites if you're going to
talk about dieting on npr you're going
to need a chinese-american non-binary
therapist and psychologist and dei
consultant to do it a mere nutritionist
won't cut the mustard
those are the new rules at npr but
actually come to think of it don't talk
about dieting at all
dieting is racist it's part of white
supremacy culture here's npr's
explanation
sabrina strings is a professor of
sociology at the university of
california irvine and author of the book
fearing the black body the racial
origins of fat phobia
her extensive research shows that the
fat phobia so prevalent in today's
society was largely a product of two
elements working together to anoint
europeans as superior to all others the
thing is the bmi was never meant to
measure individual health and again was
based purely on studies of white men
do they believe any of this
so here's npr national public radio
telling you that your weight has nothing
to do with your health it's decoupled as
they might say from your health and if
you think otherwise you're engaging in
fat phobia
and that means you
mr american must ignore the covet
numbers the numbers that suggest being
overweight is in fact a major risk
factor for death in fact the biggest
risk factor for death among the young
but keep in mind those testics compiled
by white men
the real problem with being fat says npr
is that you're constantly being
oppressed by racist diet
culture and a lot of their personal
writing focuses on navigating the world
as fat
take airplanes restaurants movie
theaters entry is limited to an assumed
body size we might consider basic
accommodations like doorways or seat
belts is value neutral but that only
shows us how much diet culture has
influenced the design of our world
we'd love to get andy tingle on tonight
to explain why the size of doorways is
racist now you probably think at this
point well they just pulled the looniest
examples off npr
nope that's a representative sample
what you're hearing there is npr's
approach to every story
so you could do actual reporting on
actual trends or stories that are of
interest to your audience and have some
inherent meaning
no
npr's decided only to complain about
frivolous questions
listen to this segment in which npr's
news division informs us that our long
national nightmare is finally over and
thank god sesame street has finally
hired an asian american puppet watch
this year the show welcomed a new
character electric guitar playing ji
young the first asian american muppet in
its history i think
you know the sort of genesis of jiyong
was accelerated with the rise in hate
crimes against asians this year
yeah the rise in hate crimes against
asians committed by all those trump
supporters that spurred sesame street
to get an asian muppet and it spurred
npr to celebrate it now this is a big
change if you remember sesame street
there was big burden cookie monster they
didn't seem to have ethnicities in fact
that was the point there was no
tribalism on sesame street that's why
they used animals not people
not anymore
according to npr the ethnicity of the
sesame street muppets is the most
important thing and not just on sesame
street and all entertainment and art and
culture
no one an npr reads books anymore
obviously they've thrown down the rilke
which they probably never read in the
first place
but they do stream a ton of garbage off
the internet and when they watch it
they're most interested in what the
people look like the shades of their
skin here's an npr producer explaining
what he's been watching recently
well kumari what tv show were you
binging this year i was watching we are
lady parts it's a musical comedy about a
punk band in london that is made up of
all muslim women
it's a musical comedy
about a punk band in london that's made
up of all muslim women
i mean okay i guess there's nothing
wrong with that but every story
is a story about a musical comedy in
london
about a punk band of all muslim women
i mean really the program is like ai
generated that's all of npr right now
listen to the question this npr
personality asks about the new matrix
film
emily have you seen the latest matrix
film i have indeed it's wonderful
no any additional trans allegories
teased in the film or is is this
something that maybe
is is being left for the first three
so if you're running a news organization
obviously one of the critical questions
you're gonna have to answer right up
front is how many trans allegories are
there in the matrix npr is doing that
and we could go on and on
in fact we could play you npr's coverage
about decolonizing hair salons and a lot
more but we'll stop because it's
tiresome and this isn't npr
but it is still not enough for npr's own
hyper woke employees national public
radio has been so thoroughly radicalized
it's on the verge of destroying itself
from within crystal flaming a
sociologist presumably studying
marginalized communities just released
this assessment of npr's toxic white
supremacy quote
the problem at npr is white supremacy
that so few are saying this explicitly
is telling indeed by the way
notice
the passive construction of the sentence
and the word indeed
signifiers of low iq just so you know
in any case a former npr co-host called
srinil miragi agreed with this quote one
thing i want to point out is the small
percentage of latino latina latinx
employees who work at npr what are we
now we
18.5 of the us population but only 7 at
npr not a good look
how upset about this can you be
the revolution always eats itself
in an npr's case it's kind of hard to
weep about that but here's the deepest
irony of all this is what you will enjoy
the very most so npr spends all of its
time attacking privileged white people
previous white people white supremacy
but privileged white people are npr's
core audience in fact they're the only
people who listen and we check the
audience numbers here's what they are
npr's audience is 84 white now we have
no problem with that we don't hate white
people we're not racist unlike npr
but
for comparison
that's higher than the numbers at fox
news now npr is always claiming that fox
news is some kind of white supremacist
organization by the way fox news has a
significantly larger black and a much
larger hispanic audience that npr has
both overall and as a percentage of
viewers
so who does listen to npr well you know
exactly who listens to npr she just
honked at you at an intersection for no
reason she was wearing a mask alone in
her subaru her picture's on the screen
right now
the question is do people like her
really need more than 100 million
dollars in federal subsidies every year
which is what public radio still gets
for some reason
probably not but then again maybe so who
are we to judge maybe angry barren
subaru drivers with as many graduate
degrees as they have bumper stickers
deserve welfare too maybe they're a
marginalized community we're not sure
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else